the kid made a final video looking back
that it was very strange and hard to
watch I just kept looking I'm thinking I
wish I could sit down with this guy and
talk before you know and I'm sure
everyone feels that way when they watch
the video as well they feel like it
cannot go away it will never go away and
the only way to stop it is for them to
go away themselves some people treat it
as almost it's like this magical thing
which can't be solved but I found
someone after they've committed suicide
there's a different kind of pain there's
a lot of questions a lot of confusion a
lot of why how could this have been
stopped you know I wasn't sleeping I was
collapsing because I was in such a
horrible place mentally the only way I
could sleep as if I was unconscious I
was just destroying myself look at you
anything really you know me I'm I'm at
23 some guy I was about 17 stored it
takes a lot to rot me and yeah I'm in
this position where I'm like what the
[__] is happening see you stand in your
bedroom the curtains are flying around
and it's windy it's obviously dark so
feels like I'm in a horror movie and
your eye feels like there's like dosser
image like just like panicking you know
I know I'm a bit full of myself yes my
self-esteem it was rock pop I mean now
just I did think about killing myself I
just absolutely did I didn't want you
but it did feel like a better option I
have poor strike stresses on not a doubt
in my mind and that really can stay with
you forever and I was lucky that I had a
close friend she was there for me
whenever yeah because that person I had
in my life wouldn't take no for an
answer
and was just there for me and almost
forced me to accept that which is very
powerful thing to do for someone in
battling those demons I had at the time
it taught me a process that I was then
able to apply to his diving to YouTube
to live events this won't be obviously
the last time this happens to youtubers
and I just hope that the most we can
learn from this experience that more we
can prevent it
[Music]
welcome back to the true Geordi podcast
we were going to do a true news this
week but some sad news of a suicide in
the YouTube community men that it felt
better to do it on a podcast it didn't
feel right to make a comedy show this
week did it no not at all it's very sad
for YouTube despite whatever anyone may
think of Etica who took his own life you
know YouTube human even though we're
like across the globe it just feel very
tight-knit and I didn't know this guy
personally but I know people who knew
and well-liked keemstar seemed have a
good relationship with him and a few
others but basically the kid made a
final video which looking back I knew it
was very strange and hard to watch
went to a bridge in Manhattan I believe
I might've I think was in the New York
area and jumped off and his body was
found a day later and for this to happen
in the YouTube world is it doesn't
happen
I'd like the thing it's because people
have got their eyes on us at all times
and if we're heading in that direction
it it'll be obvious you'd hope for that
and you'd hope that help would be there
before it got at that point but looking
at this kid's life I mean the signs were
on the [__] wall well the reason the
signs of there was because he literally
told everyone in a video I'm at this is
the end to me quite a few times he
tweeted things out yeah which were very
worrying and I think he was a little bit
of a I think because he he made noises
about this could happen to him
previously and nothing happened people
just thought I guess some people switch
off at that point and they're like it's
a cry for attention or or what odd or
drama seeking or whatever can I just say
one thing because I've really thought
about what we're gonna do in this
podcast nothing that we're gonna say in
this podcast is in any way try to
exploit the situation or
or equally trying to make light of what
happened
but I think you do and sometimes I think
the problem is after someone has taken
their own life or something serious has
happened in the community too often
we're too afraid to evaluate it in a
legal way yeah people like naturally
emotions come into it and sometimes
people avoid the truth but we yeah but
we tend to when we're avoiding truth go
to cliche and I'm not saying you are but
no I'd like to avoid in this relation is
that talk of someone if you're feeling
down stuff that comes yeah and if you're
not you know if you're feeling anxious
then you know you know going I know
people mean well when they do that but
it really is the sort of toy and the
Happy Meals you know what I mean like
it's you know everyone you get everyone
doing it and it's sort of like it
becomes worthless so I'd like us to try
and go a bit deeper today and that's for
me what kind of happened with him is I
when you said to me
oh he said he was going to take his own
life my first thought if I'm completely
honest was the boy who cried wolf the
boy the boy who continually courted
dramatic attention and then when it came
to actually needing attend and I'm not
blaming him he says that he says that in
his in his final video and that the
final video Fox I would imagine
anyone who watches it well it played on
my mind it's been on my mind every
single day since I watched it and after
he died it's like how casual he was in
joking about like I'm never gonna get to
say that end of that show yeah like and
you're like you can laugh you can this
you know this light in there there's
something in you that you you know
you're not hopeless you're not and
you're looking at this handsome [__]
young kid in America I was puppy's got
million fans and all this and people
give a [__] about him and then gone and
died that is a bit mind-blowing and I
just don't know if I could ever wrap my
head around that I think it made it like
really haunting as well because a lot of
people watch that video and didn't quite
know what to make of it because he was
so obviously telling everyone I'm going
to kill myself
but he was so blase and my casual about
it yeah even even now it doesn't
action the dramatic drastic end of his
own life noggin and the casual way he
talked about proves I think to some
degree he had his mind and his body were
not connected you know what I mean he
was just like I'm ready to go now you're
almost an autopilot at that point and if
the same thing almost took over in the
video I think one of I think that the
Robin Williams core people uses it's a
permanent solution to a temporary
problem and if you're gonna go to that
permanent place and you you think
there'd be so much rage so much anger so
much hurt so much pain pouring out of
him at that moment so for him to do it
like a casual YouTube vlog that [__]
my mind up like watching it about a bit
surreal didn't it when you watch this
doesn't it felt a bit almost black that
mirror s core sort of like a movie had
been written and someone had scripted it
I think that's why some people will be
really struggling there I know keemstar
is talk about how upset he's being at
this guy passing away because they had a
lot of fun about him forth in that and
he even mentions keemstar like I wish
you the best
yeah I mean that must be hard to be one
of the people he mentioned for all those
you mentioned a lot of people and
knowing that he you know you were on his
mind just before he died like you're an
important person to this guy that must
be hard and I mean I've talked about
this before briefly in the past but I
found someone after they've committed
suicide and there's a different kind of
pain that comes with the aftermath like
there's a lot of questions a lot of
confusion a lot of why how could this
have been stopped you know it's just
[__] bizarre that this could happen
in our community though because we I
like I said last week or the week before
last most youtubers are acting and if
this doesn't prove that you I don't know
what does because I mean don't get me
wrong it said a guy was clearly
yeah it was manic you know he was very
up and down in his videos very energetic
and he is not a classic youtuber and
that regard but it it proves just how
much of a you think you know us you
[__] don't you know I mean yeah and
until someone really pause their heart
out on it on a video and you you see it
for it is like you can't truly be in
their mind be honest though is it really
all that shocking that with all of the
circumstances mixed together this was
the outcome really if you're being
completely honest well no and I think
just because you'd think that the help
would be there for someone in in that
position but he even said I didn't want
it did you say talk to people I did I
the doors and he explains it in a way
like the the walls were closing around
me and it's just too late now and I'm
like you know as a as a person who isn't
in his mind you're thinking but it isn't
to me you're still here you're still
[__] breathing yeah you think what
I'm saying yeah like it's as if she'd
been forced into it almost by like it
was like he was heard - mine's almost it
was the control of what was going on
saying I'm gonna die now and then his
other mind talking to that like having a
conversation with himself as if it
already been made up as if he was being
like an executor or something like that
it was so there was that he was talking
as if there was an inevitability that it
where it was like this is my only option
I think that is that's something maybe a
lot of people in that situation feel
that's that is their only option and you
wasn't all the way out yeah and you
wonder how someone gets to that position
where they feel like there is no other
option
and especially when after that person
has passed away there are so many people
who say I really felt I was close to
that person I felt this I felt that and
I think a lot of people don't understand
that element of especially in young men
how they can have that it's it's it's
the pain that they're in I feel like
that's what it all boils down to is
there's a mental pain there that for
them is inescapable and even when he is
joking on the camera
on his final video inside it's so bad
it is not worth carrying or it can't
even bear to carry on and that's he was
a high-functioning manic depressant it
seemed and if it's a some extent I think
YouTube I know I'm not blaming YouTube
but made him quite high functioning
because it gives you a sort of a reason
to keep going for that period of time
doesn't it and yeah if you don't carry
on uploading all the time people get
bored people stop coming the attention
stops and I think that in that regard it
might have been a bit of a vicious
circle for him and I don't know where
we're surmising we don't know the guy
and we apologize if I offend anyone who
did know him cuz I am trying to sort of
work out what happened here in the hope
that it doesn't happen again
but it's that pain the the they feel
like it cannot go away it will never go
away and the only way to stop it is for
them to go away themselves and part of
that is that actually the mind is almost
tricked itself into thinking that then
yeah it's a bit like a computer but the
mind is a computer isn't it yeah it's
like occasionally you've got to take
your you've got a look at that take it
apart and break down what's going on
here and like have a [__] technician
look at you like go and see someone if
if things aren't making sense at that
point but it isn't as simple as that
unfortunately you don't get a a warning
error on the [__] screen of your mind
do you but you know it does I guess
frustrate me about part of this is that
we when we talk about depression or we
talk about anxiety and suicide some
people treat it is almost it's like this
magical thing which can't be solved and
respect when people don't just talk to
someone or whatever as if it's a magic
trick that you can just do that's
literally the beginning and and often if
you talk to the wrong person
it's the other worker yeah and I Spit or
if you have contact with the wrong kind
of thing so there will have been people
online who will have been saying the
opposite to what the positive people
will have been absolutely and there will
have been people who will will have been
making him feel like the walls were
closing but especially when you're a
dramatic character online right so
whenever you caught drama the the here
as commonly
was done there so like yeah yeah so the
voices would have been piling up on both
sides or dimension but do you do you
again I'll come back to I wasn't
surprised and that's what sort of feels
harrowing to me about it I'm not
surprised by anything that's happened
here
it felt inevitable and completely
expected I'm like of course that's what
happened and that's what the saddest
thing about it is is there are a lot of
factors when you read back in his story
which were feeding into that but because
they've become not you tubes are very it
normalizes extreme characters it
normalizes characters that seek
attention it normalizes unusual human
behavior it is very rewarding to those
people isn't it to people who are and
the problem is odd people I always say
to you it's funny because YouTube is
full of people trying to be cool yeah
but almost everyone I know on YouTube
including my school would not have been
in the cool crowd yeah none of the
sidemen and they probably admit this
themselves would not have been in the
cooler you know I'm saying like so they
take on them I mean know by mom using
your examples people like PewDiePie at
my school would have been bullied to
[__] right so it's sort of a place where
the different or excelling and because
it's a celebrating yeah and I like that
yeah get me wrong but in some cases
they're very very different Etica end up
excelling here as well and sometimes not
for the best reason so I think that's
the next point for me is that you never
get a community which just stays still a
community is always changing always
evolving and I think YouTube doesn't
quite know what it's created here in
mass communities that follow people and
when you have to stand out in the crowd
of people who already stand out there
already a bit weird
there already maybe the people who look
at things from a slightly different
angle that can send you down some very
weird routes where you begin to you know
you'll eat a 16 pound lobster just for
attention or you'll you know you'll
you'll punch someone oh you'll slap
someone or you'll do this or you'll do
that
you know it's yeah it's kind of like
then when when we
kids I remember people in the newspapers
people like Katie Price who she just
married men randomly just so she
remained relevant yeah is that very
youtubers now like another level on top
of that way you know you'll do even
worship and you know Jake paulandton
Aragua down the road
but weirdly and I know we criticize Jake
and Logan every week but they do have a
family around them they do have a family
and that was one thing that I took uh he
mentioned his mother it was ever so
briefly though in the video I thought
mmm
when keemstar gets more of a mention in
your own mother is that a little
indicator of what support what real
support is around you and I'm maybe he
was just in a place where his brain
wasn't acknowledging his family support
as much as it maybe should have done I
don't know but I was just trying to read
into what was going on here which is
very hard to do but I think what the
same I've been in a place of depression
before I was I've I wouldn't say it was
horribly in my early twenties right so
but it was brought on by events it
wasn't I didn't naturally just I think
with that occur I'm sure events haven't
helped but what I mean is I I feel like
this guy would have had problems
regardless of what job what lifestyle he
had it was in his a chemical thing I
think partly for hosting but for me it
was an event I said I found someone from
suicide and just boom bang like just I
wasn't coming out of the house it wasn't
told someone I didn't want to talk to
anyone and you did and when and if
someone had said that to you you
wouldn't have just off especially if
it's an Instagram story or a Twitter
post thunk off if you read that in your
and I'm not talking about being actually
depressed or thinking you're depressed
if you read that when you are depressed
you're not gonna go oh well thanks yeah
oh should have just spoken to someone
yeah yeah and to be fair maybe the
repetitive message from youtubers with a
collective of all of them repeating that
message can be a positive one however
the likelihood that that is going to
have that much of an impact on its own
is unlikely for someone who's really
really
you need to prospect I'm talking I
haven't really got a deal but like in
the past thought I would have a case of
Guinness and I do like a full full k12
2020 gig I had wine bottles like in my
my flat like I remember like you know
when one person eventually makes it into
your house and I'm like [__] yeah it's
always like a close family friend come
into my house and I was like all right
and like I can say that I'm looking
around like what the [__] like this
because I was prescribed diazepam right
from the doctor which are basically they
don't accept it if they relax you know
if you take you know if you combine them
with other things you'll be in a in a
place of extreme relaxation yeah and not
in a good way you know so yeah anyway
you can keep functioning I mean III was
I wasn't sleeping I was collapsing
because I was in such a horrible place
mentally that the only way I could sleep
as if I was unconscious right you know
what I mean so the pain I was in
internally was so bad that going asleep
away like as a normal person would The
Dream's the the etc were horrible the
emotions you know when when for some
reason when you're really low and you're
depressed and you feel awful darkness
makes it worse yeah little things like
that so I was just destroying myself
look at you anything no I like you know
me I'm I'm a 23 song guy I was about 17
stone through no phone from and I was
just drinking but not looking after
myself in any way so like for me to be
17 stone I look like [__] anorexic he
looked like me I look worse no I look
worse right that's since god no I was at
the lowest point of my life you know me
no they put me they sent me to a
counselor
the did you [__] what did you what was
your experience the counselor like what
happened there it was a bit it was a bit
like
I get it like she's in her heart was in
the right place she was this lovely
Scottish woman right her heart was in
the right place and she was trying to
get me to go through everything and
organize my mind
so making a framework feed yeah but
having that that once a week and it had
to be on a certain day I remember the
deer before being like oh yeah I've got
a call there and talk about my field
deed read it and then and then coming
out of it feeling worse than I went in
because I've had to talk about
everything I'm upset about were you
honest with her or were you right I was
I committed I was i if I'm here I'm
gonna try and be honest but then there
was days where I would just wouldn't
talk that much I'd just be like you know
I just wouldn't and it's it's like
almost like annoying scene in the movie
where you're like screaming at the guy
would tell us then and I'm like I just
want to [__] do this to do like so as
a counselor imagine how frustrating yeah
that must be my mum's accounts I've
spoken to about this before how you get
because I think a lot of people think go
to counselling I'll tell them all the
stuff and then we just go cool how do we
deal with that then and it's you're not
in that headspace when you go to those
sort of people otherwise you wouldn't
maybe be there in the first I'm not some
very some people are very organised
lives actually still go to a counselor
just to sort things through but very
often when you get sent to a counselor
it's because you've at the last resort
was that there's something going wrong
there really in in an ideal world
everyone would see a counselor maybe
once a month just for like mind
maintenance right and I think that that
would be really helpful for everyone
yeah but what actually happens is we
could work out some when we're
borderline [__] ready to finish
ourselves yeah and that isn't though the
system isn't right and it's because the
the health care system isn't right
unfortunately but will not do that to do
but the point is she tried I did try
kind of with her but eventually I got to
a place where I thought I've gotten
everything I can't
new and the real talking is the way
forward that is true but not everyone
has what I had and I was lucky that I
had a close friend who was bit all of me
who rather than a one day a week thing
where it was on their NHS's terms and I
had to be there and be in the right
frame of mind she was there for me
whenever yeah and that was like really
that's what you need and you don't don't
get me wrong it also helps if that
person has a life experience who can
really go through things with you and go
and ask you the questions to get you to
come to the right conclusions and it
just gives you that support that you
need and I was lucky because without
that person I mean I mean now just I did
think about killing myself I just
absolutely did I didn't want you but it
did feel like a better option do you
then live in Italy seriously so are you
seriously considering it or like what
what are your might like what taught me
through that well there was one night
where it was really bad weather and I
used to sit with my window open and I
woke up at about 2:00 a.m.
and I'd moved into a place where like
the windows were sort of hard to shut
sometimes big big [__] windows and
like I just woke up and I was really in
a bad place and I remember the window
wouldn't shut and the wind was [__]
blowing really part and I was sort of
like I think I drunk that night before
and I'd taken like my ideas panel and
like the curtains up low and all over
and I'm like in the dark and I'm [__]
like free surrounding there was like a
moment where I was like like I mean I'd
had panic attacks many many times before
that but I remember it was a very very
hard one because that's what comes with
depression isn't it xiety and those
talking with me and I'd never known what
it was like yeah I didn't understand
anxiety I didn't even know what it was
like I'd never it was
like being on a [__] roller coaster
but you're just sitting in a [__]
chair in the living room thinking why do
I feel like this so I think the best way
that I can describe anxiety is it's the
same it you know sometimes you catch
yourself maybe getting a bit angry and I
specially you but anyone I think patches
themselves getting a bit angry and you
can sort of go okay let's just take a
step back and just breathe out anxiety
is when you can't do that there's no
bricks almost yeah there's no it doesn't
feel in your mind there is there are
ways of stopping it and I've you know
you don't have them at the time yeah you
can you can learn them and they become
very effective if you go to the right
talking boat the first exactly the first
time that happens I think that and I
think the other thing we should carry
out the with this happens to a lot of
guys or early 20s you begin to work at
how big life is you're beginning to work
out what your responsibilities are what
kind of man you are becoming and you're
worried that your experiences are
shaping you in a bad way maybe at least
that was I get these messages on it on
an almost daily basis yeah where there's
a lot of young lads going through this
and nobody's really what I find weird is
nobody is taught these really simple
ways of dealing with those things like
we're teaching [__] PE yeah you know
what I mean laughs this really should be
on the [__] curriculum buck hockey I
think it's a good idea I mean just
hockey I mean badminton producers yeah
well ever yeah um you know what I'm
saying like these these coping
mechanisms they shouldn't be something
we have to struggle to find out I think
the other side of it is these should
also be something where we go this is
actually something that you maybe need
to go through in order to grow up like
you will naturally feel anxiety at some
point you can actually feel sadness and
I'm a pretty in control guy though as
you know takes a lot to shake me I can
get in a [__] in middle of a boxing ring
for 20,000 people on a microphone and
and Britain and people watching a whole
millions and millions concurrently no
but but what I'm saying is it takes a
lot to rock me and yet I'm in this
position where I'm like what the [__] is
happening so you're standing your
bedroom the curtains are flying around
and it's windy it's obviously dark so it
feels like I'm in a horror movie and
your eye feels like there's like ghosts
around me and [__] I didn't think there
what I I didn't know what was going on I
was I like just like panicking would you
have bad dreams and stuff
I mean when when you have a trauma I
mean I had post-traumatic stress
disorder
that's a [__] not a doubt in your
mind and that really can stay with you
forever I still have bad dreams
absolutely almost weekly because it sort
of shapes the roots that your mind goes
down the way doesn't it when you go
through if you have any experience where
you find someone in that way or you have
a personal experience that is very bad I
know people who suffered attacks or
whatever it never fully goes away so you
need to learn how to deal with it and I
think the other side of that is it's
also that you have to have gone through
it to understand what that would be like
and I think everyone says that but I
think very often if so say you you're
telling me your story now I can relate
to it in a way that maybe I've had a
similar experience I've never had your
experience so I don't know how intense
that is for you or I don't know how its
impacted you and in many ways it's a bit
like you know when you go and watch a
film you go oh that was bad and then
afterwards I'm fine
omit there was one night I remember just
getting so like blasted would you just
drink a light oh oh yeah in complete
silence you're one TV right Grand Theft
Auto that was that was my only thing I
used to do is play Grand Theft which my
life right and probably on the way I
would but then if I if I had like I got
to a point where I had like a girlfriend
or whatever how I know but well you know
I just I just you know what I'm like so
anyway I don't wanna make light of this
but just like I wasn't I don't know why
I can't decide I would but I think in
some ways they just saw me I was like a
project oh yeah after a bit and I wasn't
taken advantage I wasn't even thinking
on that level I was just like I'd make
them go to the shop for me I'd make them
go and buy my beer I would they be
buying like 20 packs of Guinness I'm not
no I'm not love yeah I'm Jenny like
stunned that someone would consider not
as a girlfriend then go I'll go and get
you a twin I just stopped getting
haircuts right so my hair was getting
like really long like how long are
talking but my hair was longer than your
hair like really long no one was seen no
but it was really unlike my beard but I
my beard wasn't calm down
okay I stopped looking at them he looked
like guys get in the shower but I didn't
give a [__] about my Charles so some
things never change
it's all okay so but I remember there
was pointers I haven't been outside in a
week like or whatever like so I wasn't
in a good place and I remember one night
I got up and like I I sorry I was
throwing up one night from like the
state I was in
and up I was alone and I started choking
right and and I was like okay I'm gonna
[__] like a [__] die here like I'm
really panicking
that's funny other thing that'll make
you panic and and that was sort of a
very scary moment way just so [__] up
and there's no I didn't do this to
myself because I thought what I don't
want to do was glorify or romanticized
struggling and being in pain you know
because I remember when I was younger I
thought there was some sort of
achievement by having the hard life and
there isn't but I was in a bad way and I
was just self-destructing and I thought
I'm gonna [__] end up killing myself
here by accident alone [__] on poop
yeah and weirdly that I think that
fright made me it made me realize
something a little bit like I'm taking
it to levels yeah where I'm really
really taking the piss but also that you
do actually want to live rather I think
that that the pain didn't go away but
the the fight was there in me you know I
was really trying to [__] hurl this
[__] [__] about my lungs or whatever
so the fact that I'd cared enough to
[__] do that and I didn't just give
up I think was a little bit of her all
right well no there's something there
that gives a [__] even if I'm not
enjoying life in any way right now and
and the talking to the person really
really helped me and and gradually I
started caring more about myself but it
was a very slow it took me about four
years
and for years - to start like looking
after myself again and like really being
normal to some degree you know it was it
was [__] hard life
I've never told you that before I know I
know yeah
why so within those four years like what
were the steps like step one is like
talking someone step two was just
getting out of the house step yeah well
the thing is I can't compare myself to
Etica at all and I'm certainly not
trying to do that because Etica I feel
like should have been on medication and
I was given medication but I didn't take
it so I wasn't working they put me on
like they were like you can't [__]
work and are absolutely are not [__] me
yeah so they put me on like whatever the
income support give me some little very
very little money but no isn't a lot
it's it I think a lot of people sort of
go oh you're not have a job you can go
no it's nothing
it is like I was a teenager living with
my parents and I remember when I first
graduated my dad was like if you're
going to be applying for jobs you might
as well go and sign on yeah it was like
it was barely enough for t know if you
were selling to him the things you've
got to go through to get you ridiculous
certainly don't have depression yeah I
tell you that [__] and very often
there was humiliating you get there and
I know this is a very clichéd story at
this point but you get there you're
around other people who are of a similar
mindset to you because they've got there
obviously things aren't going incredibly
III didn't fit yeah but some of the
people around me made me feel worse
yes and you and Mia Mars bar as this
couldn't and you but you end up on that
sort of is this what I'm like I fit
right I am part of that group and you
start to identify with the that aspect
of it and then you walk into a room and
someone goes I'll just name you know I
know I'm a bit full of myself yes my
self-esteem was rock bottom I I felt
like everything I thought was gonna come
in my life was never coming
yeah I felt like a failure I felt like I
was letting people down
I thought hold on a second like I'm
intelligent
I've got abilities in areas I'm
literally just gonna I'm gonna be like
no better than the [__] dregs of
society and it begins to feel inevitable
I mean I it was like it's never four
years it took me a [__] sort that's I
mean I wasn't I wasn't not working for
four years but you know I'm saying like
mentally I was there mm-hmm like I'm
[__]
yeah like and so you can begin to relate
to what Etica was going through because
it is that element of it felt were the
walls closing in on him that's what you
said sort of thing and I get that I felt
that way and there was a Nevitt book but
I kept thinking to myself like when I
hear all the young people sort of say
they're struggling or whatever like for
me I look at a guy and I think you're
you're worshipped by people like you are
the I think that the core than the
jaikon boys they're his crew and not
they loved him you know he was an
entertainer they was a [__]
entertaining guy from what I've seen
like you know I mean he was divisive
clearly but he was an entertaining guy
I'm like there was so much for this
person you live for whereas for me as a
young kid in Newcastle who just you know
couldn't get out of bed let you know
didn't want to leave the house for weeks
and on an end and stuff I felt like the
walls are really closing in do you think
part of your route was shaped by the
stories that you knew because one thing
I definitely got from when he was
talking I was there is this idea which I
think a lot of people should try and
avoid if they're trying to go into the
creative industries of this paned artist
this person who like you said has to go
through pain in order to get to the good
because those are classic stories those
are you know just enjoy you had to fight
the dragon all you've ever going through
for me it wasn't that because I had no
intent of ever being a creative art
being on YouTube but you can still end
up being a pained person and you like
you said you get told like with hardship
comes blah blah blah not me because I
cast myself as like
strongman yeah and I think that even
that even and I [__] know I'm strong
so so that even made me feel like more
of a failure like because I've got that
expectation of myself and my mind of
being a man who just get on with it and
is strong that's when it becomes even
more humiliating for our own self
because I'm like and I heard ethic I
used these words as well about how he
was like you can't be a [__] you can't
be a [__] I'm gonna cry now not gonna
be a [__] like he said that like as a
joke on himself like he was still
keeping that up to the end of like I
don't want to look a certain way I care
about how I come across even though
internally that the turmoil is there and
I and I get that I think that's why I
just stopped leaving the house or
whatever general I mean because I was
like I don't want people I know what to
say me you know face up to it know with
because if someone looks at you when you
haven't had a haircut in [__] months
and whatever and you just don't care you
feel even worse than because it's a it's
it becomes real so while you're when
you're pushing self-destruct in private
it's like no one cares about me I don't
care about me so this can continue no
one will ever know but then when someone
who looks at you and I think because
that person I had in my life wouldn't
take no for an answer
and was just there for me and almost
forced me to accept that which is very
powerful thing to do for someone that
made it real that the judgment of oh
look at all these wine bottles and look
at all this god I can't believe you
doing this and like I was like yes bar
doesn't like and made me feel like she
cared and therefore I couldn't really
carry on doing that in myself like I'm
not saying that was the strength
completely but it gave me something even
though I felt like a letdown to her it
was better than just carrying on in my
own private space letting
self don't it's or confirms it in a way
is it facing up to it you know this is
happening yeah because in grand theft
auto or like it's silly as it is and
this isn't an advert for that but it's a
little fake little world and in my head
I was like you know I'll just do this
instead said a real life you know I mean
like I'll just blank everything out I'll
do this I had a bit of cash in the bank
and when that runs out that was the
thing in my head I remember thinking
well when the money runs out then maybe
like then I might just do it all right
you know I mean like there was little
things in my head like I wouldn't accept
like reality or consequences or and
that's another thing I think I mentioned
in his in his video as consequences and
you know that I'm gonna have to pay out
and I'm gonna have to that was time
where I've got a like face up to what
I've done and stuff like that for me
that I what I found so difficult about
that was it was so cryptic or at least
it felt cryptic maybe there were people
in his audience again where I completely
understand what you know it wasn't
easily understand and I felt a lot of
that was him explaining himself like in
his own to himself it's yeah yeah and
and affirming those struggles and sort
of and at least acknowledging it that's
what I'm saying those when you're about
to do that there comes a day where
you're like what I'm saying me and him
are different but and I'm not but I all
I'm trying to do is relate in any way I
can here and I remember just putting it
off and being like well I'm not enjoying
life now I hate life now but I'll play
it out for now to see if it changes and
then if it doesn't then I'll do it
weirdly that's kind of what the mind
does to it keeps it keeps putting so far
a he just keeps and and and they and and
I guess that my moment was down the road
there and I and I was getting [__]
close to it looking back at it because I
remember I mean that person let me money
and really helped me go in that
situation but like yeah it was a it was
there and I just luckily had someone put
their hand out for me before that
happened
yeah [__] mud was part of that for
years like reprogramming the way that
you thought about life then it was
making my circumstances better but you
have to go through action to do that so
you have to tell your brain you can't
sit and play Grand Theft Auto all day
you can't sit and drink twenty Guinness
well it was breaking those Hubbard's
yeah and making that cycle so it was
about just trying to find good habits so
one of the first habits was go back to
the gym right find things I like that
weren't bad for me you know and when I
uploaded that first youtube video I was
definitely still about a year a year
before the end so the first night ranger
video I still had another year of like
getting out of that Mendeley so one of
the things that pulled me out was
realizing that I could have a career in
YouTube and not have to do something I
didn't like anymore because I'd stopped
dive and I was like [__] that [__] it
probably not in the right mind space I
mean I did go back diving after like the
bad times and I [__] you know when
you've got anxiety you don't wanna be
put in a tight suit on an angle at the
bottom and see if you've got anxiety
don't [__] deep-sea divers who ever
have an anxiety at the bottom of the sea
then he's also taking deep so this is
the point is you can have anxiety
attacks when when you're just a diver
yeah when you're fine because it is it's
a hellish job at times it's almost a
natural reaction to being put in a suit
and then Center what to do I swear to
god me I'd say the half of the diving
course is just stop panicking right
that's yeah it's the [__] first like
month of diet
do they ever induce a panic attack to
try and make you know what that feels
like because one of the first things
they did me I remember they they put you
in the water with no gloves on and I and
I was like why do you do that and they
were like because you'd be worried about
the cold and you'll stop having a
[__] panic attack because you think
[__] me I'm freezing got you something
else to worry about
but yeah it kind of is I remember when I
had cancer
so CBT therapy which is cognitive
behavioral therapy breaks down your
behaviors and basically makes you
reflect on them I know I know a rape
victim who had that right but so so CBT
yeah you don't to say CBD because those
are two very different things
yeah and and so they would basically go
through the same process of you work out
what your mind thinks why your mind
thinks that way and then you work out an
actual way of dealing with it rather
than the way that your mind has already
come up with so you break those thought
processes and so for me it was anxiety
and I had anxiety around whatever you
know and we broke down right why do you
why does your body see that as a threat
why are you reacting in this way and
then the best thing that I ignored was a
lot of these are perfectly natural ways
for the body to react so anxiety is
actually very natural way to react to a
threat because your body feels
threatened it feels like you has to run
away so your heart rate goes up you
begin to sweat all these kind of things
and so breaking that down I think is is
really healthy because you begin to
understand that's where my brains going
wrong or like that you know when you can
when your brain wants to go straight you
actually need to take it right a little
bit all you need to take it a slightly
different direction and it gives you
that feeling of control and I never had
that but one of the most valuable
lessons I've had in life from from where
I was a guy who was not coming out of
the house for you know months at a time
to hosting ksi versus Logan and being in
a highly [__] everyone's watching me
situation think that I was now anxiety
attack was learning that control over
that that what would and what would not
so so in battling those demons I had at
the time it taught me a process that I
was then able to apply to diving to
YouTube to live events to what and it's
a very healthy skill and that's why
we're saying people should really be
taught this sort of stuff in schools
because pressure
of any sort will [__] be difficult to
deal with any and I've seen people
struggle with pressure a lot because
we're in those situations where you know
on a live show and things like that you
see people struggling with things like
that
I think when we first started the live
shows that say there were times where
like we were both struggling yeah not
would like the pressure of people
watching you but like maybe the pressure
of keeping it going all the little
things there nothing and that's not it's
not real pressure pressure no obviously
diving is harder but or it's all really
the same I think that is a really good
point to make is because a lot people go
was just YouTube why would he youtuber
kill themselves come on he's got a great
life or and it takes away that human
element which actually is everyone's in
their own little bubble and especially
on YouTube exactly so sort so for
example to someone else my life is very
simple and straightforward because
you're not in my head and but to me the
podcast the kickoff true news it means a
lot it means a lot and I take it all
really seriously adds someone who is a
diver or works at a shop or wherever you
know we all take we're all in life
seriously and I'm sure and now if you
watch Etica you can see things meant a
lot to him and and there's like I think
I'm lucky that I got through all of that
before YouTube because there are some
things about YouTube which when you
become a youtuber promote unhealthy ways
of thinking and there's like an
endorphin kick that you get when you
release a video and it bang yeah and
again and for me it isn't really about
the numbers the way it is with other
people but there's a there's a when I
feel like I've done a video that's got
something to it there's there's a
meaning there where I've separated
myself from what everyone else does at
times I get a kick out of that
yeah and if I do if I I've noticed like
with us not being doing as much of the
podcast lately I've been missing that
feeling and then when we did the podcast
recently when people like the other oh
yeah I'd be missing doing that and so I
can only imagine if you are
the way he was those extremes are a lot
higher and a lot harder to control and
handle and especially in I think gaming
and your audience but in gaming the
reactions or the reactions are different
you've seen his reactions when he did
things on his is he he was a big
Nintendo switch player yeah yeah he
would react and you know I'm sure people
loved that ball so it takes a lot out of
you in a weird emotional way and I think
the the other side is for him it it will
teach you because actually reacting in
that way in the beginning can feel quite
easy it can feel quite well that came
out quite easily and everyone loved it
yeah [__] you Muni for example when
people would park things there was a
there was sort of a natural reaction I'm
sure getting a big player and then and
then a year went by in two years on
buying people having the exact same
reactions and you're like why are you
still yeah and I'm thrilled about
Ronaldo and big and it wasn't about
Ronaldo it was about the views it was
about the whole thing that was in people
get carried away because that that is
actually a really good analogy for
probably it's a really obvious way of
breaking down what happens on YouTube
the person was no longer excited for
Ronaldo they were happy and excited for
the consequences of getting the renowned
dogs are exact and it being like I can
react to this and I've got my title my
thumbnail and there's a relief there
because they're putting hours and money
into opening pucks and they're just
praying they get this one [__] player
to make it all worthwhile so there's a
relief as much as anything and I think
that is just as fitting for him as it is
for everyone on YouTube but it does
teach you for me it's bugging a good
guest it's big so when they walk out in
the cards turn around yeah he's no messy
we've had it we've already packed it he
was in team in the season that Daniel it
teaches you I'd say a bad thought
process a it's not healthy because
YouTube as a system just rewards a
certain thing in it and in order to
achieve that you've got to think a
certain way and
if YouTube rewarded quality programming
over sensation and his titles we'd be in
real trouble we'd be lucky not I just
think we'll be better for Korea's I
think would be healthier for the
mainstay and I think that as much as I
as much as I don't for example just and
I'm not relating these two subjects
worth what happened with Logan was
definitely a result of his mind state
which was as a result of the YouTube way
of gaining success and he obviously took
it too far he did the wrong thing but
more things like that will happen
because of the way youtuber so and I
think part of that part of the problem
is I think we often have these
conversation people go social media
social medias bad isn't it and we all go
yeah social media is bad they go
it's YouTube's fault for the algorithm
and you go I don't think YouTube told
you to make that kind of thumbnail
auditory act in that way monkey see
monkey do so when you've seen another
YouTube you do it you go that way and
it's also it's also it's not it's not
necessarily all YouTube's fault by any
means it's its nature of people we drive
past a car that's had a car accident and
we look because it's i/o and it's for
the same reason when a sensationalist
title that you know nine times out of
ten is a [__] video behind it but
you can't help but click on it ten times
it just it just in just in case you know
what I mean so but yeah yeah and I think
I think also the the ability to hide
behind editing hides the reality of the
youtuber mind state as well so like
that's not a snide dig at me by the way
no I like like I said like youtubers are
fake people and I don't mean that in a
nasty way I just mean they put on a
persona for the camera and then the real
them is often very most time very diff
in the same way you'll do when you go to
school or when you go to work or when
you get but these people more more
exaggerated distilled so the real person
and the the person at home is just fair
the report then what you'll see from a
[__] fireman or whoever doesn't that
teach people but that's the point though
is I think I used to stream a lot and
you know when you stream as we know when
you do a podcast a lot more comes out
right you know what I mean and I think
that that didn't help him either because
people see in a lot of moments where
they picked at it in the like with the
podcast this the comments are always a
lot more because people say so much more
of you there's so much more to unpick
there's so much more to have a go at you
yeah and I I notice that like when we
started podcasting that there was just
so many little things I was like for me
there's never happen I did like five ten
minute videos like mmm and for that
reason because not like putting a
[__] stop stop story out there or
anything but I Eve as I've told you
privately haven't felt great for the
last few months and that's why I haven't
really done any podcasts like yeah I've
been struggling with guests as well sort
but I didn't really want interview
anyone I didn't really want to do these
type of videos because it all just would
come out you know I mean sounds I can't
[__] just leave it yeah you know me
and I think Etica having some one day to
pull him out of that situation would
have been very healthy for him because
he was going into it you know I mean he
was [__] live in it like though he
was shouting the revolution will be
televised I think to a police officer
mm-hmm and I think I don't know what he
meant by that but I think his his end
was televised in many ways like for him
he was talking about his life his thing
his
what he was going through I think a lot
of people are surrounded by like black
guys a cliche but it eludes something
and I think a lot of people especially
on YouTube will go down that route where
they'll look for meaning in these big
phrases they'll find and things become
quite extreme very quick and there's a
there's a sin of going out in a blaze of
glory I don't know about glory but when
people when things go wrong on YouTube
it's it's it's hugely over exaggerated
the whole James Charles thing earlier
this year I mean what even what did he
even do you know I mean what did he in
the grand scheme yes yeah and yet you'd
think you'd away YouTube reacted and you
think he'd [__] killed someone like
it's ridiculous so when you are feeling
like that is going to be ten names
[__] worse and like the walls closing
in mmm which I mean credit to James
Charles for coming through that I don't
know he's a strong like I've got respect
for him after that I do it does I'm not
and I'm not getting into this place
where we go what examples that setting
for the kids well somebody's please the
give the children the other side of it
that is when you're watching someone on
YouTube you do naturally your brain will
go oh I like that aspect of them Alan
I'll take that for my personality all
right oh I'll become a funny well
there's no audience they call them
influenced us for a reason not just cuz
they need a one key name for agencies to
use yeah they are influencing people but
in not not always in the way that you
think that they're gonna move so in a
way people are well you sell them
lipstick or you'll sell them you know a
new gaming controller or whatever the
other side of influencing is the
subconscious level you pick up
mannerisms are you pick up you know I
was I was obsessed with them at em when
I was a young teenage kid like
everything about him the way he dressed
away though we talked I adopted so many
little things from him that I was
totally unaware of like my heroes when I
I mean Alan Shearer I was my hero when I
was a really young kid but like I
remember like I liked Stone Cold Steve
Austin
I like mm I like rebellious sort of
don't open don't give a [__] car
dozen but M&M yeah like I look back at
it and I realizing Claudia I was
obsessed with this guy like every word
every lyric I knew the podcast would be
very different if he'd taken on an
island Sharona it would just be you know
he didn't take on his persona but you
know what I'm saying so so I know what
it's like the to feel like we'd call
them stands for a reason like the way he
wrote that that song like I certainly
wasn't on that level but I know how to
feel like you really almost care about
this this star and I we've been to
events and we've seen the love that
these youtubers get in ocean we found I
can only imagine though what kind of
things they taken from these youtubers
on a daily basis because the difference
between youtubers and musicians and
movie stars
is they see them a lot more real you
think you know them a lot more and
they're almost you can reach out and
touch them you spend hours with them
every week they're not one album and
then a year later another album and this
is why I'm trying to caution people when
I say you think you know these youtubers
you should [__] don't you don't and
that um sort of risking a little bit of
people not being happy with me
personally for that but it's for that
the actual audience is sake I'm saying
that because I don't think it's healthy
for people to just believe this is how
people are and I don't think that the
I'm not insulting anyone's intelligence
but I just think it's it's only natural
sort of thing youtubers are a more
genuine breed than it's never seen but
they are not they're just the same as
anyone else in the public eye they go
down a road where they protect their
image they want to come across a certain
way and ultimately they want to make the
most money and convince people of what
they need it would not keep their career
going and keep that audience I think
that's what I find of interesting is
something I know this is stupid
someone left their laws them group the
other day as laws things like a group of
people who Joe King like what a [__]
rough people love Lawrence and they've
got the wrong to our group but it's sort
of evolved where people have gone this
is stupid not really leveled up me
in the image of their God so the the
main thing that I felt like an element
of pride when this person when I'm sort
of done with this now I was sort of like
oh you've completed the journey like
you've graduated from me and now you're
in a year old from the University of
Laws sure or whatever you want to call
it know it and what was weird was I felt
like I wonder the School of Law's me but
does that person you know what's weird
though is it's like the contrast of
feeling that you have when that person
goes not I'm over you and you know
you're nothing to me but that's all sure
that's probably what this colleague but
and but they go I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna put LM CK my name anymore I'm not
gonna do this larysa I don't know
they're gone can we check on them I the
other side of it is oh you're so you've
graduated you sort of an adult now
you're you're a real person and you
don't feel what I don't want the loss
limbs who are still in the group and on
real people know heard it from your own
career we still love you
yeah hello saying life oh Sh I could
hand out like a piece of paper flying
I'd be weird not recruit more of them
sure you don't need them no one wants
alright so I I hear what you're saying
people and and what I'm trying to say
from the youtubers perspective is they
go down that road as well and it's just
not healthy for them so I don't know how
I don't know the [__] way out that's
the thing you know i mean it's it's such
a rewarding road to core so say you have
no career skills you have nothing you've
not did
maybe you've developed editing skills
ism like that but in most I mean let's
be honest we've seen mostly youtubers
they haven't they've got editors do
their [__] how they need them there's
also the other side of that of losing
not losing face but sort of having to go
into an office and someone saying to you
what have you done for the past five
years and your own I was a youtuber Yeah
right okay I think there's only a few
youtubers who could pull that off and be
like alright then
so like Chris MD right he'd be fine yeah
he transition in office I have no
problem absolutely I can suppress in
them morning Chris morning laws good see
here how you doing just be like just got
to work without deadlines yeah but Chris
why are you wearing a waistcoat in the
office you look so dapper from a new
you can see a card you thought I'm
saying that like yeah this there's some
people who would ya know who would be
fine regardless of where they were yeah
Steve it is it is I mean like I love
Stephen a bit but [__] me if YouTube
didn't exist and comedy didn't exist
what would like you if thank God for
YouTube thankful I mean I say the same
oh and meek in me included that's what
I'm saying it's in many regards YouTube
saved me in many regards and I know that
that sounds so like it sounds good in it
but you know no I don't mean that in a
in a in the traditional site you know
it's only traditional sounds Disney it
sounds dislike I mean like oh you've
saved me like but if it wasn't for it I
would have ended up a very sad miserable
[__] right that's what I'm saying
instead you are just a miserable [__]
but I'm not on the dole anymore right
you're not a minute in many ways you've
trapped yourself in another way and I'm
not saying this an ironic way where now
you're you are you have to upload your
part of the YouTube system going but but
I didn't know that I really wanted to be
a creative person because in Newcastle
if you're a block your grandeur just
goes to you get a trade you know what I
mean like I remember being I was a
natural artist at school right I thought
you're gonna say natural bricklayer no I
I genuinely am everything all the time
and yeah but I'm not grind not great at
anything I'm not sayin I'm great in
anything but I was just good at certain
things like oh and swimming and being
strong but but but I remember being like
I used to draw for hours and my granddad
would be like not get you anywhere and
then I'm like paying a tattoo artist
[__] hundred pound an hour or
whatever so that the point is I could
have been a creative and being very very
happy and I think that that was what I
was truly searching for and YouTube just
happens to be an avenue work and finally
do that and enjoy my life but it was I
was pushed away from that I was told
become an engineer become
you know a tradesman is that because
life is not as crude as picker job
become the job be that person and it's
the same thing but it wasn't my grunt
does do though and I just and I'm sure a
lot of young lads north of probably
gotten to although exact same thing and
for some people that really works well
somewhat it really is of cord they smash
it and but what I'm saying is I wasn't
built for that and I didn't know because
I'm thinking well I'm a man I can do
that and I was just not happy in it you
know what I mean
and I do really what I should have been
doing is trying to find something I was
passionate about and to go for it I get
what you're saying the other side is the
world cannot be all artists and creators
unfuck because they're [__] wonky
people we are but I do I hate I do
dislike the idea of finding your one
true self or the one thing right because
I think for someone like you it works
out really well you can tell that story
backwards and go but I found what I love
but there are people out there who found
different things exactly the way you're
I'm not saying this story badly but some
people watch that and go well I've gotta
find my one thing then and some people
become obsessed with this one thing and
that's somewhat what YouTube relies on
is that these people go I've got this
massive audience I must have been
destined for this this is my thing I'm a
cook that's what I'm trying to not say
so I don't look back at it now and go
this was all meant to happen
because as easy as that is to fall in do
some things because I look at certain
moments and I think wow that was amazing
I guess I must have been destined for it
but what I'm trying to say is no it was
create creativity which made me happy
and if I had found that being a tattoo
artist or writing stories or not yeah
being a voiceover guy or what I don't
know doing little things he's good at
all of him he's available from all if
you know but like there's just different
things you know but I'm just saying it
wasn't about that it was just about
finding something that gave me a reason
when I was in that really low place to
get out of bed and when you are
rock-bottom if there's a thing you enjoy
light that can be the difference between
in bed and ending up at the end of that
road which you think one day I'll just
[__] off meself and finding a reason
to be like not actually like this is
kind of fun I'm enjoying like finding a
little thing to take pleasure of in that
moment can change the direction of your
whole life so you created some meaning
in your life really yeah because I was
like well I'm enjoying this actually
like and I hadn't felt that feeling
diving made me a lot of money and I have
such a laugh with the lads I was making
solid money in it and but I wasn't I
didn't enjoy the job and once I stopped
going and I didn't see a reason to go
back and whatever it was just a bad road
as I was saying so um whereas there was
a passion there was a reward I felt from
uploading a video you know even if it
was a [__] video at the time or whatever
I was like oh there's something to this
do you think do you think if you had God
or if you'd have had something with a
higher meaning in it then your path
would have been different
I'm kind of a pleasure seeker so deep
that you don't you know I am you know
I'm so guilty of that but you shouldn't
have to deny God to find play and I'm
not saying I believe I'm not I'm not
denying God I'm just saying cuz the way
my brain is built and I fully understand
myself I'm a person who seeks that
reward who chases that dream that
pleasure that that spirituality wouldn't
have been enough for me it wouldn't
really I wouldn't have ticked that box I
need more I need or not necessarily more
but I need that feeling do you think
that's what some and I'm not saying
you're wrong do you think that's what
some people tell themselves so that they
don't have to face up to that spirit I
know you're quite a spiritual person but
some people tell themselves that because
they don't want to face up to having to
go through that spiritual journey so for
some people it's easier to go on this
ego filled YouTube journey and again
this isn't a sliding key that some
people got in that ego filled YouTube
journey where you can avoid being
spiritual because there's
there's no video where I turn on it on
YouTube and I go this guy's just
meditated for six hours and then had a
meaningful moment and then he's turned
his camera on and expressed that like
YouTube is quite a meaningless place it
is you know there are morals all over
the place that people are breaking every
day we're very judgmental in all our
videos there's sex everywhere there's
all these things that I'm not saying the
Bible's right but it does game all those
things that every religious book and
every spiritual book warns you about and
there are people out there who see it as
shirking responsibility or people who
want to just live a childish life their
whole life and it did look to me like
oetiker had sort of he didn't have he
haven't found that quite found that
meaning which would have kept him around
maybe oh definitely I agree with what
you're saying and that felt quite sad to
me because I felt like he'd almost been
misled by the dream of YouTube or if I
like he'd been misled in some way to
thinking this was the right route and
then he'd been backed into a corner and
it didn't feel he didn't feel good to
watch oh it was it was awful it was
absolutely awful I didn't even know the
kid and you know I was sitting watching
TV like a day later two days they are
still thinking about that video yeah I
wished I just kept looking and thinking
I wish I could sit down with this guy
and talk before you know and I'm sure
everyone feels that way when they watch
the video as well yeah there is the it
is a it's bad to be that pleasure
chasing you should encourage that Oh
YouTube encourages that absolutely
people like me tend to succeed in it for
that reason and the other side of is and
we've had this experience with YouTube
if you do get down the road where you
maybe have made a mistake or something
goes wrong there's not all that much
support from YouTube to help you reverse
or help you to get out of it yeah for
instance the channel disappeared very
quickly I've got a lot of learning to do
because for me one of the things I will
say as I said I don't know the guy but
the eagle of a youtuber we all have this
and for me one of the things in my ego
is that I'm creating something
building something that is like a big
house and every day is a brick going
into that and and certain videos are
like the foundations of this [__]
work that I'm putting in yeah and I
guess somewhere in my head I'm thinking
well one day when I'm not here people
will still enjoy these right no they
might not watch them every [__] day
there's a youtuber by the name of rich
Piana who was massive in the bald body
building YouTube world and mmm he was
very passionate and controversial guy
but I enjoyed his stuff and you know his
channel still there this day he's got
like a thousand videos million
subscribers people just watch him
whenever they want and it would be
heartbreaking for a youtuber to put all
their was hours into a channel and for
your audience who've got you there and
loved your stuff to not have that ago
and your family to go and watch those
videos so I think YouTube really need to
reinstate his channel I know he may have
broken a few rules right on certain
videos if he did you know take them off
or whatever if you have to do he's also
not here to benefit from that anymore so
why try to enforce those what the
problem is is they've acknowledged him
on Twitter but it
I don't he shouldn't be a dirty little
secret of YouTube he and in if they feel
a bit like oh you know he got wrapped up
in the YouTube game and this ended up
happening maybe if we just you know so
that is not what and I don't think they
have done that because his YouTube
channel was deleted before he died but
the actual final video they took down
there's less words and for all they
might be a bit hard for people to watch
they should be oh yeah they should be
there's [__] because that's someone's
memory I'm someone's life that's his
last words I was really struck by that
and not that you've actually kind of
triggered that in me that I remember
thinking because of the cycle of YouTube
some things that you know we were talk
about this when we talk about the
kickoff and clips and all these kind of
things is
it's here and then in the next week it's
irrelevant or it is sort of gone and so
you begin to treat all the videos that
people make in that way but actually
someone's put a lot of time of effort
and a lot of thought into each one of
those things I'm not saying they're
learning you know made laws up or
they've done anything particularly
brilliant but they have put time into
that and they are that these are real
people yeah so like appreciating their
time in their effort and what they're
going into YouTube all stuck to us yeah
as youtubers because everything that we
make they tick off you know I'm not even
talk about the problem it's building it
they [__] network we're building it
for them
Internet's doing the work for them all
you've got to do is make sure the
website doesn't crush the internet and
they're doing a reasonable job of that
in an existential sense you're actually
putting your life into this you're
putting your time into it oh if my
channel you know got deleted I'd be
[__] devastated you know I mean like
this it worked really hard on this and
if there's something really meaningful
about it there the fact that he's not
here anymore
[__] right man because imagine
imagine you know for example just going
for an extreme example but imagine
tomorrow
all of a sudden Michael Jackson and
Elvis's music was just gone the funds
would go [__] mendel now I'm not
comparing the work of this kid to them
but for his funds that's how it feels
almost you know what I mean and I just
thought that's [__] out of order that
but because because videos are going out
so often and very often people I have
one bad video the next one will be
better you don't treat a weirdly I don't
know why people don't treat YouTube as a
craft because every other thing if
you're going to TV everyone talks about
it because then can do it but any bit
underrated massively because you get Tod
because because it started out with
people uploading videos their [__]
dogs doing traits yeah
then it's under a lot y'all get Todd
with the same brush in it I just find
that so wait but even the dog doing the
trick that person is taking the time to
teach their dog a trick and then film it
anyone can do it boom yeah that's their
attitude though that I'm saying I'm not
doing that my opinion of it so you
saying because it feels less rare it's
like it didn't feel like a dime it's not
a Netflix sure is that that's what
they've got there that's the way people
judge it you know I mean I get what
you're saying
personally I care moving forward on
YouTube
I am worried that we're gonna see more
of this and I just hope that what we've
seen happen with that guy shows people
how not to handle things a little bit
and and we we take as many lessons from
that as possible because YouTube is a
baby of a company and we are all sort of
finding a lot of things out first
hardened so I just thought that people
can take as much from that as possible
in not going down that road and and when
we see the science as an audience
flagging it and enforcing something to
be done next time I guess that's part of
it because he was looked up to a lot of
people thought well he must be dead he
must be fine because he managed a man
yeah and men are looked at differently
than women and I think that that's why
there's a there's a real obviously man
and women commit suicide but there's a
thing going on in the young male
community isn't there where part of the
problem is we're supposed to be the
strong ones where so there will be must
be strength and yeah we will bottle
things up and we will internally destroy
ourselves rather than come out and talk
women are so much better at talking
about feelings and supporting each other
through [__] than than men
oh you've only got to look at you know
like prison documentaries and stuff you
men are busy trying to take over prisons
and be the the dominant one in play
political roles women are cuddling each
other like here's a totally different
nature they and then that is one of the
reasons why we are [__]
opening up and helping each other it is
that right I've got very close friends
who I love and care about like I never
really ring any of my mates up and go
I'm a [__] day man like I think we do
mm-hm and this isn't the not on any of
my other friendships but I don't do that
with any of my other mates and it isn't
because I don't feel like I can it isn't
because I think that they would treat me
badly or give me bad advice
it's the hobby right it's the it's the
habit of being in and also I think
where I'm from so I one of the things
that I've picked up from being around
you I remember this is a funny thing
that bring ups when I first came to
London when I first met Lawrence I
remember I got out of car we were half
drum and we were being shot Norah and
we'd sort of we hadn't we'd been talking
a lot on the phone and being mates but
we hadn't met each other that much and I
remember you hugged me mm-hm and there
but you hugged me like a whole range
yeah yeah and I was like nobody really
hooks me like that in Newcastle like it
was sort of a strange thing I was like
all right this is what London is doing
over tuxedos like you quite taken aback
a bit like I'm not I wasn't being like
no no no yeah gay boy come across it
wasn't that it was like oh he's good
he's different I guess in like you know
I see layer Brian Oh lovely little
squeeze yeah it was like you are very
sharing and you are very like mature and
you talk about your feelings so being
around you even though I have all those
internal thoughts are always and I've
always been like alright face everything
head-on and deal with it I don't usually
up my mouth and tell someone that so
being around someone like you has been
good for me to be that way but I still
wouldn't do that with anyone else
because I just haven't broken that cycle
with other people I think it's a
difficult one to do isn't it yes and
we're not so good at that they all tell
each other [__] everything we say
nothing like it's annoying me I do find
that weird because there is like power
in the collective of things when you can
share like we I know I don't know what
it is and again we're talking about as
if it's magic but as soon as you've told
someone a problem it does tend to change
nature of it it's almost like your mind
suddenly goes ok well that's how it's
real now so how do we deal with that
yeah and I think that that's the reason
why people say talk to someone I'm not
that much most people don't really
understand the full I think the full
workings of why that helps but it does
help for many reasons and that is one of
them is air becomes real so it's
unavoidable so you're not [__]
burying your head in the side be
someone else knows about it so they can
help you and give you any advice or even
just let you offload that and as men we
just need to be a lot better I think men
a lot of men and maybe a lot of women as
well are worried about being exploited
for the information they give away so if
you told someone you were anxious and it
was at work that person then goes well
no promotion for you do you know what I
mean and although that is a worry
the lack of trust is a huge thing and
those are very untrusting quite a lot of
the time yeah but you're not I'd say
you're naturally a very trusting person
when you get to know someone but I
wouldn't say you're a trusting person
I'm definitely not trusting let's be a
bit part of that lets you being quite a
powerful person in yourself but I'm
loving but it doesn't mean that I'll
give people information willingly yeah
it takes a lot it took my [__] lot
and that's a probably a flaw of mine but
that comes down to how you see power or
how people perceive the dynamics between
people I don't even know I think which
one of those learned things that you
yeah I but I've just grown up that way
of like yeah don't because I was let
down by people you know people weren't
there for me who should have been there
yada yada yada and you just think now
just keep lie to yourself yeah and this
strength and information you know know
me and and and you think why would I
want to give that up why would I tell
that person because I think we do live
in a society where people are sort of
taught that power you hold the power and
you keep it and then you wield the power
and but more and more and I think what
the internet was trying to get at was if
you share that and it becomes a
collective thing then actually you can
make everyone more powerful but because
and I think especially on YouTube and
Twitter where you know there's a limited
amount of money or brand deals or these
kind of things a lot of people want to
keep their own castle build their own
walls and then whatever comes annual
it's your money it's your audience don't
share that that's courage and I've had
my heart burned a couple of times where
I feel like I've helped people on
YouTube and you know it wasn't the right
move or the right person health right so
maybe that's partly but it's not just
YouTube that's just life isn't it
everyone we've all helped people get a
job our promotion or introduce them to a
girl or you help them in any way and you
regret it later on but it isn't healthy
you just think and this is for people
not just men just because that person
[__] me over doesn't mean the next one
will we've all I'm talking too loud see
we've all met girls who their
ex-boyfriend
track them like [__] so now she makes
you walk through fire just to prove that
you're not a [__] as well right like
that isn't a healthy way of doing it
like so
bime it by making the next guy walk
through fire doesn't mean he's gonna be
any nicer like he could be just as big
of a [__] and just pretend long enough
to get away wants to be let's toss the
point I'm trying to make sorry is I
think give everyone a fair chance of
getting close to you and of course
sometimes you're gonna regret that we
have to go through that but trying yeah
yeah try and trust those people because
that that's why I've changed later on
and I through you plus is but because of
you a lot if you've rubbed off on me not
literally
well that was it not recently good cut
yeah was give more people a chance
basically right and if you are in that
that place if I'd had a mate like you
when I was in that dark time it would
have been a lot easier is what I'm
saying we did a multiplayer oh yeah I
see
we are here for each other I think that
no and that is yeah but if I'd never I
didn't have am a it like that back then
general I'm saying and it took an older
woman not in that way yeah um you know a
very caring person to come in and help
me but the more people around you can
have like that the better so yeah
bring bring the defences down I think
it's my Mian thing I want to say to
people about that because I think that's
one of the hardest bits of when people
say talk to people it's also just
letting people in
is [__] difficult in it especially if
you are anxious or you are depressed
because actually your natural reaction
is to defend yourself and especially I
think it's also very natural that if you
were so for instance you know you can
relate it to it being in the wild or
whatever if you are disoriented or
whatever you'll naturally just swing if
something comes for you because you're
worried it'll be an attack and your body
will perceive it that way even if it
isn't so it's about breaking down those
natural very natural thought processes
and explaining them to yourself and this
is what I try to say it were person I
spoke recently who lost someone what
you're going through is normal yeah and
because it doesn't feel normal
when you lose someone especially a
suicide like I say you go through all
these questions all this pain all this
heartache your brain goes through people
say are you going through the stages in
it isn't a formulaic thing you don't
have a 10-step plan to being firing
after grieving for someone sometimes
you're at this point the next day you're
at that point it's all [__] over the
place you're in pain it's all normal
yeah and that is a really important
thing to cut yourself some slack if you
want to go out and get blasted sometimes
that's okay as well like you don't have
to feel guilty about it it's just when
you get at the point that I get ya
should we should we wrap it on that
because I feel like I don't want to I
don't get too preachy I feel a bit bad
when I don't feel like I'm that guy for
that but yeah I'm glad we talked I'm
glad we talked about it today
RIPD I'm very sorry for what happened to
this guy and yeah we put some things in
the description below to donate and
stuff like that I know it sounds cliche
but I do hope that in in what happened
to him it doesn't sort of go unnoticed
or unadorned that's what we're trying I
think the best thing to do is to
remember it and but I wouldn't say cut
McCall a cautionary tale but see someone
who lived such a great life and still
ended up in a situation where they felt
relatively very sad very sad all right
thanks everyone who joined us today
don't forget to Like and subscribe I
tunes were on Spotify and all that goes
again we'll say as Leia you never hug
now okay that's it good one guys make
sure you get the awkward hug in at the
end